In the past few years, many Republican governors
have signed legislation targeting
LGBTQ people into law.
"Two controversial bills are now law in Alabama."
"A bill regulating what school bathroom Oklahoma
students use..."
"A house committee passed a bill
focused on pronouns."
And hundreds more of these bills have
been introduced in state legislatures.
More every year for the last 3 years.
The laws are increasingly focused
on what sports teams
transgender school children can play on
which bathroom they can use,
and about the use of pronouns.
But, these bills are at the state level.
If you looked to the federal government,
you’d hear a different message
to transgender students.
“We’re here to say that’s wrong."
"And it’s against the law.”
That’s because the current federal government
believes gender identity discrimination
violates a 1972 federal civil rights law.
So when it comes to the rights of trans students
conservative states and the federal government
are at odds.
But the enforcers of education policy are
a third level of government:
local school boards.
And they’re caught in between. With
extraordinarily high stakes.
I was thinking, wow, there's no way I'm ever
going to vote yes for this.
Gender affirmation is suicide prevention.
This coming year will be my seventh year
teaching in Tennessee.
I'm seeing a lot more depression,
a lot more anxiety.
I'm seeing a lot, a lot of suicidal ideation,
which the data bears out.
One estimate says that 20% of
trans and nonbinary youth
will attempt suicide.
That's two times the rate
of their cisgender peers.
And other surveys on mental health
and trans youth
find that they are more than twice as likely
as cisgendered children to experience bullying
or to not attend school because
they didn’t feel safe.
I do have a transgender son
that is 17 years old.
I live in Murfreesboro, Tennessee.
Almost nowhere have more anti-LGBTQ bills
been introduced this year than in Tennessee.
And at least 2 anti-trans laws related to
participation in school sports and bathrooms
have already gone into effect.
Tennessee’s bathroom law allows “students,
parents or teachers” to sue schools
if they “allow a transgender student in
the bathroom” of their gender identity
“when others are in there.”
In our school, the rule is trans kids either
have to
use the restroom designated for
their sex assigned at birth
or they need to go find a single-stall
gender-neutral restroom.
And our campuses were not built that way.
From one end of the school to the other,
upstairs on this end and downstairs on that...
The one time that Toby decided to just go
ahead and go into the male facilities
they started chanting.
They started beating on the stall door.
You're asking a kid to fight through dysphoria
and put themselves in harm's way.
In 2021, when the Tennessee laws went into
effect,
most school boards adopted it as policy.
But not all of them.
"We are being asked to pass a policy
that goes along with state law, yet it is
a violation of civil rights."
This is the Metro Nashville Public School board
which governs this school district of roughly
80,000 students
discussing whether or not to adopt the state
law that bans “transgender athletes from
participating in girls' sports"
"...in public, middle, and high schools."
"It is a moral and ethical dilemma for me as
a board member."
It was not something that anyone on our board
was willing to make the motion to pass.
"The focus has just been wrong
like how's this something that we're placing
at the feet of our children?"
"All those in favor of deferring policy 4.301
raise your hand."
"Okay, unanimous."
We're in this place now where we as a district
have been able to say:
There are adults and people in charge in your
life who support you and care about you.
And so the thought that our hand may be forced
to implement these anti-trans policies is
very scary to me.
But that decision is in a legal gray zone,
and it could have consequences.
School boards, states and the federal government
all play a role in US education policy.
But states in particular have the most power
over public schools within their borders.
That's because public education in this country
is traditionally funded by property taxes
which are not federal in nature, but
they're state and local based.
School boards can set their own policy
but when states pass laws related to public schools
they are obligated to adopt them.
If they don’t, they risk...
Funding, funding, funding all the way.
That's a threat that hangs over our heads
pretty consistently.
And I mean, we can't function without that
funding.
Typically, the vast majority of public school
funding comes from state and local governments.
But a small portion does come from
the federal government
mostly through programs related to equity.
Like for students with disabilities
and for students living in poverty.
These kinds of resources augment what's
available from state and local funds.
Even though this slice is small
any school that receives
“federal financial assistance”
is beholden to Title IX
the 1972 federal civil rights law that,
for 50 years,
has ensured that there is no “discrimination”
“on the basis of sex.”
And for public schools, the federal agencies
that enforce Title IX compliance
are tied to whoever is in the White House.
And the past three administrations have differed
in their interpretation of Title IX.
The Obama administration ruled
that it protects LGBTQ students.
But the Trump administration reversed it.
And the Biden administration restored it again.
That’s why today, in 2022, it is a violation
of federal civil rights law
to discriminate against LGBTQ students
in public schools
which could make a school district liable
to a federal investigation
while some states, who control most school
funding,
have passed laws contrary to that.
So school districts have to figure out
what to do.
And so do the families of trans students.
I would say it puts us in limbo because
while we feel heard and appreciated
by the local board
the state is still saying that
they're not welcome.
So what do you do?
It makes all of us want to move.
I get a little fuzzy about some of it
because the federal law says
that you cannot do this
that that supersedes the state laws.
But yet they still do it and then they cite
Governor Lee's bills as a reason to discriminate.
In states like Tennessee, this legal limbo
could eventually be solved by a lawsuit or
federal civil rights investigation
that could overturn a state law.
There is already a federal lawsuit on behalf
of a trans teen boy in Tennessee
suing to play on the boys’ golf team.
And there’s a federal lawsuit over Tennessee’s
bathroom law.
But those won’t necessarily change things
outside of Tennessee.
The institution with the power to do that
nationally
and that could force harmony with federal,
state
and local policy would be the Supreme Court.
But if those rulings don’t come out
in favor of trans students
the last line of defense will continue to
be
those closest to them.
Teachers are going to be a big part of saving
kids' lives.
Depending on just how willing they are
to be supportive, to be affirming.
School has always been that one place
where we can hopefully find somebody
who will love us and value us for who we are.
Is there anything else you'd like to add,
just about your personal experience?
I could share one thing with you.
I came across this.
Last weekend was Pride.
She was very excited.
This is what she sees, right?
There she is.
And there's all these people
supporting the flag
and they're, you know, giving her hearts
and fireworks.
And I'm so thankful that this is how she feels.
I can't imagine that if she did end up going
to schools
or being put into a situation where
she wasn't supported
and celebrated, that this would
not be the case.
I mean, this is clearly the world that you've
created for her.
I am not very good at taking credit for things,
but I'm pretty proud.